all right let's call Ben Higgins we'll
see if he answers I've got a little
mystery for you to solve I'm here with
someone you know I want to see if you
can guess who it is she is very sweet
she loves dogs oh she's a brunette
currently in a relationship a very happy
one then you are embarrassing yourself
right now it's time for roses and Rosie
my queen it's so good to see you thank
you for being here how are you I'm good
I'm so excited to be here I'm so excited
to have you here the last time I saw you
you were falling out of a plane
yes and today's a little more low-key
yes however till is it because we got to
see if I can answer these questions okay
of course this is Rosalyn was a sip or
spill I'm going to ask our beautiful
Bachelorette Becca Cooper and some
questions and she can either answer a
spill or sip take a drink of our little
bachelor nation tea or either they're
gonna sip the tea or spill it
we wanted to get some minty fresh tea
pinkies up yes because we were told that
I'm in the bachelor world you're
constantly being given like mints and
Listerine strips oh I wanted to a
promotional like thing with blistering
cuz I put so many in my mouth through
the season like the most because when
you're filming you can't eat obviously
when you're on set so if you do have
these weird hours without meals and so
half the time I'm like can I just have a
list arena I'm hungry
all we had on us so you're constantly
popping those terrine strips did you
ever have a moment where you wish
someone had popped one that they had not
on the show yes I'm not gonna give a
name though because what are you still
with that person no such it's so weird
his breath always smells good even in
the morning
and it's kind of annoying cuz like I'll
wake up and I'll put the sheet over my
face man hi good morning I love you and
he's like hey breathing on me I'm like
it's not fair
good morning breath what a treat okay so
who had the bad breath okay let's take
it back and we'll ask you some questions
about your time and filming as the
Bachelorette sip or spill what's one
thing you wish you could take back or do
differently from any of your time on
reality television not say yes first
engagement and I choose you today but I
choose you every day from everything
else I feel like had to play out as it
did too well that's interesting though
but it because if you hadn't said yes
you wouldn't have been necessarily for
sure but I know right well that's the
truth yeah so I don't know but no but I
see you're saying yeah that was pretty
rough I want to take the risk and see if
there's a possibility with her um
actually I gotta ask you re just said
even though he was engaged to you at
that point he said he went on winter and
games because he wanted to see what was
up with Lauren and he wanted to talk to
producers about it did you see that I
heard that I actually heard it from
Rachel which and I think this is what I
told her to to me it's such BS because
when we were together I knew he felt bad
about like how things and that he felt
guilty which I get because it's a very
weird situation but I was always like
you can go call her and like apologize
and get that off your chest it was never
something where I was like he can't do
that
so to me it was weird in that regard
also there's like a lot more I think
that I didn't ever know about that went
down so it's like at this part point in
my life and like whatever I was
surprised he said that and to hear him
say that it seems like he's just
admitting that he was hiding feelings
for another woman that he was having
fear you like it makes it all seem false
that's how it looks I know like many men
I think he was confused at that point
okay but what a beautiful that was like
the southern woman saying bless his
heart
have you guys ever talked again no no I
mean just like filming wise but that was
it yeah
nothing else no and I don't know what
would you say if you ran into him I
don't even know what that would say like
huh I'd probably high-five and be like
yeah he's a cute baby yeah have you and
Lauren ever talked
no mm-hmm how would things be there I
think fine I mean I think you'd be fine
for me I mean at this point like they're
happy I'm very happy with Garrett that I
don't think there's any hopefully
there's no bad blood there but yeah I
don't know I mean a bachelor nation it's
like everybody runs into each other
everywhere at something we're gonna
we're gonna run into each other at some
point I know it's about to happen but
well cheers to rising above well thank
you and being very happy meant to you -
you're very - thank you we love being
happy we love a good man sip or spill
who made the worst first impression on
you ever in bachelor nation this one's
very easy so night one his name is
Camille
he went home night one but he's the one
who he walked over the limo and he's
like let's meet 50/50 and I'm like great
that's what I wanted a partner and then
he's like well actually
how about 60/40 and then like Sept away
from me and I was like you coming closer
to me I remember that I tweeted about
that guy it was so rude yeah it was not
okay who is the biggest diva in bachelor
nation right now I would say well and I
love her but I would say Demi just go
she's like a sassy lately she's been
wearing that like cute little pink fur
coat
she's a diva in a good way yes do you
know Demi we do diva sip or spill Blake
do you have a history with but did learn
I thought she loved me back well a lot
went down with Blake in Paradise and a
lot of it originated at stagecoach Blake
has said he's gonna go back to
stagecoach was this the right decision
okay
I keep saying this you could not pay me
enough to go to stagecoach so for me
personally I'd say no but he is still
single and I think it's a good way for
him to meet someone to potentially have
a great night with so maybe for him yes
depends on your priorities yeah I would
say uh okay far far away from stagecoach
people this is a woman who has her life
together giving me advice mm-hmm here's
my thing I think it was all blown out of
proportion and this is why like he was
single the girls were single like they
can do what they want I think the thing
that bit him in the butt is I mean he
made his bed and he had to sleep in it
in the same location as like multiple
women so I probably would have
approached it a little bit differently
but I mean like hey if you want to do
you and have fun at stagecoach do it
like it you know in this day and age it
shouldn't be that big of a deal should
blink go back on paradise next summer I
think you should take a break from maybe
TV for a little bit okay
yeah all right let's talk about you and
Garrett because you guys are so happy we
love how happy you are so I think you're
probably gonna answer a lot of these you
guys moved in together mm-hmm what is
the best thing about living with Garrett
I think the best thing being with him is
just somebody to always do everything
with like I love to cook so I just enjoy
having him sit and talk with me and like
drink wine while I'm cooking also one of
the best things is having our dog with
us I feel like we're one little cute
happy family all right now we're gonna
be some rapid fires about life living
with Garrett okay Becca kufran sip or
spill who's Messier me who takes up most
of the bed when you're sleeping you know
who is a bigger spender definitely I
feel like Garrett's pretty simple
Garrett has the same flannel shirt that
he adds all the time it doesn't mean
much if you're arguing who needs to have
the last word me what is the grossest
thing Garrett's ever done in front of
you I mean he goes to the bathroom in
front of me all the time we've gotten to
that point where we don't close the
doors anymore do you fart in front of
each other yes yeah we again like we
have been with each other so much
constantly on the road that like there's
no we anymore what's one thing there
does that turns you on this is could be
a very weird quirk but he likes to rub
my ears which feels really good you're
like a cute little dog yourself I know I
know but he like just rubs my ears were
laying there and it just feels so good
that like I like to snuggle in more than
kiss up on it and like know it yeah
there we are never look at ear having
the same you know you guys have been
together for a while and I are so happy
have you talked more about the wedding
stuff no I think we're just taking our
time okay I mean he was and they said
this on the show he was previously
married in divorce and so I never want
him to feel rushed or pressured into
anything so I'm I'm fine with where
we're at I'm kind of just waiting for
him to be like okay let's do this now
have you talked at all about what you
would want one day when that comes a
little bit I think when that day comes
we just want it to be a massive party
okay I want it to be like food trucks
all over and games and just like one
massive party and so that's what we've
talked about I think we would like to do
it in California on a vineyard but then
just like catering all these trucks and
have like cornhole and I really wants
you bald okay like fun things like that
details is this a TV wedding in your
mind televised I'm not gonna say yes or
no but
as I'm right now probably not okay yeah
Farrakhan is looking ring I feel
beautiful this ring it I mean me away
nobody's doing Neil Hiller that's a good
one but let's do some sipper spills
about you going on tour okay so you're
going tour for Bachelor live on stage
sixty-six stops with you and Ben Higgins
together described yes are you sharing a
tour bus that's like the one thing
everyone asks we have separate tour
buses because Garrett's gonna be with me
with me with me part of the time Jessica
will be with Ben I'm like we need our
alone time hey you didn't want to do
like no that would be too close for
comfort
yeah it's like and like you know if
there's only one bathroom on the bus and
like I'm not we're not all sharing a
horse company yeah how is it going kono
statement Ben what have you learned
about Ben
I mean Ben's awesome at what he does we
have to learn like our lines are staging
changes choreography everything and he's
just really good about picking
everything up so quickly but like making
everyone around us feel comfortable - so
I'm like dang have some big shoes -
alright
sip or spill will we have cameos from
other bachelor alumni on the tori well
we will yes hopefully a lot alright I
want to play a little trick on Ben right
now we're gonna try to call Ben and see
if he can guess who I'm with and if he
doesn't get it it's like Ben you better
get to know your co-hosts either get
something real quick all right let's
call Ben Higgins we'll see if answers
he's probably like doing something for
charity I know he's done in the Honduras
only hanging out with his mom doing
something I don't think so nice for his
girlfriend wow I'm good I've got a
little mystery for you to solve I'm here
with someone you know and I want to see
if you can guess who it is
all right she is very sweet she loves
dogs
getting any hints yet she's oh she's a
brunette
she loves wine supernet I don't know
I've got a lot of highlights wrong okay
what else can I give you currently in a
relationship a very happy one and you
are embarrassing yourself right now this
is something okay all right I'm gonna
try to get more specific had one of the
worst breakups in bachelor history a
really rough one but now very happy with
me the way to make it hard for you but
I'm really concerned about what you
think of brunette is hello and how are
you okay then how are you going to be as
a tour mate 466 stops with Becca kufran
it's okay I'm gonna be the annoying
sister wonderful all right thank you so
much for your time
oh wow he sucked at that dude some work
to do with him we got some work to do
luckily you have a lot of tour stops to
do it that we cannot wait everybody go
get your tickets for the Torah beckon
but are going to be adorable so much fun
and you can see someone find love and
see me dance and see her dance all right
let's finish our tea Becca Cooper and
cheers to you thank you very separate
spells
bye guys can you say bye you with me
yeah okay three two one bye
[Music]